don't recognize when you go out and you
dress and you speak who do you represent
when you go out as a woman in the
relationship your husband right so when
you're at school and you're in uniform
you represent the school yeah when you
go out as a child you represent your
parents if you have a man you represent
your man you're a couple so people are
going to know that if he sees you on a
on a podcast and you're doing God knows
what you're going to represent him
people are going to know that's
so-and-so's woman so you have to listen
to him you don't don't he doesn't tell
me what to do but I have to take his
feelings into account
do you flip that do you flip that and
does he represent you as well when he's
doing stuff yeah well then the U.S do
you have authority over him to give him
permission to do stuff or not yes
certainly he won't do anything that's
everything it works both ways but you
said you have but he has the final
decision
okay okay yeah he has the final decision
if he's going to do something and he
says oh I'm gonna do that and I'm like
you know I don't agree with that because
it's been so long 32 years and counting
because it's been so long he will he
will know that there must be a reason
behind it that I don't agree with him
now he will even listen to me as I would
do him because I don't have to take
everything he says as gospel it's up to
me whether to take it or not but nine
times out of 10 years I will listen to
him rather than listen to my friends
want to finally listen to their friends
what about most of us that haven't had
32 years and so why are you saying that
I've been with my man two years and I
must what he says goes this is what my
struggle is what I'm trying to say is
you've been able to build that trust you
you've been able to know that he's got
your best interests at heart yeah you've
been able to know that he has your
rights your right intentions but most of
us haven't had 32 years to practice all
that you know that I can't adopt your
position can I say something do you know
something right you as a woman would
know within the first six months whoever
that man is for you I can't say that I
would know me personally I would know I
was a single parent just like you I was
a single parent and we split out but
when I met him back he was a single
parent
so I know that anything he says if it
jars in my heart I have to think they
must have been know what that don't feel
right let me discuss it but if I think
to myself I am not going to be a
detriment
then I'll go with it because it's not
harming me
so every everything in my head as a
woman that what he's saying doesn't
benefit me or harms me I will discuss it
and then because it's not the fact that
oh what he says goes I will discuss it
with him and I want to hear where he's
coming from because all right then for
instance you've got a man and you both
use grab a favorite artists
and the favorite artist gives you two
free tickets to go
and then your man looks at dick and says
you know what you're not going what
would you do
like this conversation is gonna happen
with my man anyway honestly I think that
I think the modern relationship is way
too uh it wasn't no let me say the
modern relationship I'm looking for is
way too equal in terms of opinion and
position and there's there's a
conversation it's about what's making me
happy and if it's taking my best friend
to that concert he wants to see me smile
and he wants to see me happy that's
what's going to happen in that concert
but he didn't answer the question so the
question was I asked you what would you
do like when he asks you to do something
that you don't want to do
but if it's in my best interest I cannot
put myself the only man or the only
being is God that can tell me by speech
by Grace
God says obey your man the man
he's my man he didn't put a ring on it
you should be with him until you put the
ring on it right but what I'm trying to
say is if I'm a feminist what does it
mean for me as a single woman that's
what I'm trying to understand from this
conversation okay so can I try to add a
little bit of context on it because it's
like a okay so basically what what
they're saying is okay so yes working
taking out the rubbish doing all of
these things are seen as as masculinity
right however I don't think we're
speaking in that regard because
obviously these are things that have to
be done you have to take out the rubbish
you have to work you have to do these
things but I think we especially as a
single person however we're basically
saying but you're still a feminine that
doesn't make you masculine what makes
you masculine is when and you're like so
let's put everything in context now so I
said I made the same statement as Auntie
right
so I'm gonna put things into context if
I wanted to go shopping in Tesco's for
example I don't need his permission
right because I'm going Tesco's and I'm
doing food shopping if somebody invites
me to a club
or some kind of event
then I need to sit down and speak to him
and explain to him where I'm going what
type of event is what kind of people are
there all right let's let's say for
example I'll put an outfit on and I put
on a short dress and and my breasts are
revealing okay now if he says to me you
look nice babe
go out and have a good time
as soon as he's finished that sentence
me and him are done because me I can't
be the guy like that to me that's a simp
okay so if my my man or my husband says
to me
you need to go back and you need to
change because what you're wearing
is inappropriate now look a lot of
people will be like no why why I compare
what I want if I want to work but you're
not you're not thinking because if you
if you're going out with your husband
right and you go to a club or a place
and you're wearing a short skirt and
your breasts are out you'll there's a
huge possibility that you're going to
put your husband in a situation no but
he's next to me
when you're talking let me laugh let me
land okay so for example my fiancee
right if me and him went out to a place
and he wouldn't let me wear that anyway
in the first place but let's say he did
and we went out to a place right and a
guy comes and and Taps my bum
it's less likely right and if he does do
that if I had a bbo you will attack my
ass not necessarily but look look look
we we have to go about intentions if I
come to a place and I'm properly covered
up jeans and a guy does that he's
getting smoked right there's no if so
but about it because this girl is
respecting herself she's dressed up
nicely and you've come out of your way
yeah and you've you've slapped her ass
now my fiance if he was with me right
and somebody did that
there's a huge possibility he's going to
jail for life but then you're wearing
tight jeans why not wear this on long
skirt in it if we're going if you're
going to do more you're going to do what
you can wear along
no nothing you can that's what you
should do then because no no you're
calling for it also with the little
tightness getting away from the clothes
get hold on getting away from close you
guys this is what I'm so confused about
it Auntie you kind of did it and then
walked to a more agreeable area do you
guys talk about things that are basic
relationship Norms but you like frame
them in the most toxic way possible I
don't understand so you talk about like
if I'm gonna wear something and go out
to a club my boy my my boyfriend my
husband whatever is going to approve of
it which it to some extent like can make
sense in a relationship context but if
you flip that around if your boyfriend
or husband says I'm gonna go out to
party you know and there's like you know
10 girls there and like two guys I
imagine you have to okay that right
you'd have to tell him whether or not
you give him permission to do that no
yes okay so you guys frame these things
like my my husband is the ultimate
Authority and blah blah but that's not
true for all you guys it's a back and
forth like you're gonna be okaying what
he does he's gonna be okay you do that
has nothing to do with masculinity or
femininity or anything like that that's
just like two adults having a
relationship figuring out what the
boundaries are thank you yeah so so what
do you mean by your place when you say
auntie because what is he saying this it
is an equal exchange of
um looking out for each other no I think
I'm different because if I'm gonna wear
a short skirt and something sexy I'm
always going to work with them with my
man mostly I wear it at home
but if I want to go out and I'll say to
him would you think about this and do
you know what
what um Destiny said
what we've been saying it's just normal
normal respect for each other
and I respect him and his decisions and
his opinions and he will respect mine so
it's not like I'm blindly following
where he wants to go because if he
wanted to go somewhere or talk to
certain people other sit in the past you
know what I don't like your friends
and as a man I would say you know I'm
not going to sit down guy if I'm not
saying this watch out for this this is
what I spotted this this this and this
and I'll let him go ahead and eventually
he will not you know what you were right
so it's just about respect but I find
that these modern people now they don't
have the basic respect for each other
and as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible